>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE SUM
OF THE BLUE JACKETS FAMILY
SUFFERED A TREMENDOUS LOSS WITH
THE PASSING OF GOALTENDER MATISS
KIVLENIEKS.
TONIGHT, WE HONOR THE IMPACT HE
MADE ON HIS LOVED ONES, HIS
TEAMMATES, THE BLUE JACKETS, AND
OUR COMMUNITY.
TO COMMEMORATE HIS LIFE, THE
MATISS KIVLENIEKS MEMORIAL FUND
WAS ESTABLISHED TO SUPPORT THE
YOUTH HOCKEY INITIATIVES IN
COLUMBUS AND IN HIS NATIVE
LATVIA.
THANKS TO THE GENERATION OF OUR
FANS, AND THE McCONNELL
FAMILY, MORE THAN $100,000 HAS
BEEN RAISED TO DATE AND HIS N
NAME.
[APPLAUSE]
THE COLUMBUS BLUE JACKETS
FOUNDATION AS HONORED TO MAKE A
DONATION OF $80,000 TO THE
LATVIAN ICE HOCKEY FEDERATION TO
SUPPORT AN INITIATIVE THAT WILL
PROVIDE CLINICS FOR YOUNG
GOALTENDERS IN LATVIA.
[APPLAUSE]
WE ARE HONORED TO HAVE WITH US
TONIGHT MEMBERS OF THEIR FAMILY
JOINING US FROM THEIR HOME IN
LATVIA.
PLEASE WELCOME HIS GODFATHER,
SISTER, STEPFATHER, AND MOTHER.
[APPLAUSE]
AT THIS TIME, WE DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE RAFTERS ABOVE
THE TEAM BENCHES AS WE UNVEIL A
BANNER WITH HIS NUMBER 80 WHICH
WILL BE PRESENT AMONG US FOR THE
DURATION OF THE 2021- 2022
SEASON.
♪ ♪
>> WE NOW INVITE TO MATISS' FOR
THE CEREMONIAL PUCK DROP.
♪ ♪
WE ASK ARIZONA COYOTES ALTERNATE
CAPTAIN ANDREW LADD AND BOONE
JENNER TO JOIN THEM AT CENTER
ICE FOR TONIGHT'S CEREMONIAL
PUCK DROP.
[APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
>> THANK YOU.